[Music]
[Music]
hello my name is zachary levi i should
have a little tag and i play shazam
we all established something very
special on the first movie and and
shazam theory of the gods we expand on
that
now they have to balance their life with
being superheroes this is where you hang
out with your superhero friends isn't it
these goddesses
come to our world
our incredible new villains
lucy lou and helen mirren
she's kick-asses calypso
we have mythological creatures minotaurs
harpies and dragons
when i talk about upgrades we got an
upgrade huge upgrade in the suit bigger
action sequences bigger set pieces we go
from athens to philadelphia we go from
the rock of eternity and the library of
eternity to the realm of the gods so we
get to go to environments that were
never explored in the first fall
we have it all three two one
shazam fury of the gods
[Music]
takes the excitement and the action
to a whole new level
it's going to be more of a spectacle
this is fun all around
you're in store for a treat y'all
[Music]
you